good evening it all comes down to this
tomorrow is election day and while
there's a lot of excitement in the air
some are preparing for potential safety
problems
thanks for joining us here at 11 i'm
denise valdez and i'm brian loftis
police as well as local businesses
stepping up security for the big night
orco mana joining us live tonight from
metro police headquarters
with more on the precautions they're
taking orca
brian and denise there's some concern
that as election results start rolling
in there could be potential protests
that's why metro police and local
security companies are getting ready to
respond
if they need to be ready
then you know get caught off guard
retired cop and security expert jonathan
simon tells me a proactive approach to
safety is key on election night this
year with the country so divided police
are gearing up just in case
metro saying it will have patrol
officers and sergeants available to
respond to potential incidents at any of
the 125 voting locations and there will
also be 600 other officers and
detectives on standby
something should occur we have any type
of voter intimidation
any of those type of things any rights
any protests we can get law enforcement
on site quicker
while police prepare simon and his
security company are also on guard
they've been hired to protect this
nissan dealership on east sahara as well
as some other businesses with armed
guards and air support drones again this
is all precautionary we will fly the
area
to see if we can detect anything that's
happening away from here
up to three miles even a couple shops
downtown are boarding up ahead of
election night commercial surveillance
company stingalarm says for those that
are worried make sure all cameras and
alarms are working
it gives you that peace of mind that if
and when you need the system to perform
it will be performing optimally this is
serious simon says regardless of the
results it's better to be safe than
sorry i have a presence
here to be a deterrent to anything that
may occur
metro will have their deployment
operations center here at headquarters
where they can
monitor any potential safety threats
like they do for big events such as new
year's eve and nevada highway patrol
will also be here
to help coordinate any responses
reporting live tonight from metro
headquarters orca mana 8 news now